I want to make sure I mention your book
too you've been busy you have a new be a
schnor which is a yish term meaning like
I learned that word from Gro marks okay
yeah he h used to sing a song about
being I'm not a snorer which I think was
uh yeah my captain Spalding I think has
the word schnor in it my name is Captain
Captain Spalding the African Explorer
I'm no snorer hooray and I remember as a
kid as being a huge fan of the marks
brothers and thinking schnor what's
snorer yeah and then someone explained
it to me oh that's a great feeling for a
Yiddish well a Jewish person who knows
some Yiddish to explain it to somebody
because it when you show interest we get
very excited yeah it's you guys have the
you guys and I say you guys I mean the
Jewish people have the greatest phrase
of all time which works for everything
oi oi and it's perfect and you know what
it's perfect for texts because people
tell me stuff and it's really heavy and
and you don't have time and sometimes I
just say oi and they're like yeah and
you picture you can picture the face the
Emoji that goes along with it and it's
yeah it's the same face of when all the
pastrami falls out of the sandwich it's
it's Billy Crystal's Mr Saturday night
character that's what I picture um so
Misfit growing up awkward in the 80s uh
is is your Memoir yes and was this
cathartic for you because you've
famously you've talked about it a lot
and I think uh very um you know people
say oh it's Brave and I it's like well
it's it's it's great that you talk about
your struggles with mental health and I
applaud that but it's that you do it so
with so much empathy and you do it so
intelligently and you're funny about it
oh thanks and I think that is a man
that's a bomb that's worth that's all
that's worth all the Prozac in the world
you know I mean it it was something that
I aspired to over the years to
finally get to a point where I was far
enough away from it that and and also
that it was sort of a a a success story
of I overcame this because in the midst
of it I wasn't able to write about it
and also my brain wasn't working well
enough and I didn't have enough
confidence but I was so elated and
grateful to be on the other side of my
depression which I was I received
ECT about four months before I did that
that abbreviate the states thing and
really yeah and so the electric
convulsive therapy in in I was impatient
in in um wild Cornell Hospital New York
Presbyterian in in Manhattan and then
and you said one of the patients
actually Rec recognized me from from TV
and and yeah he said uh am I crazy or
you Gary Gman which is I mean you can
write an entire
act apparently
both um you are crazy but I'm getting
that from Context yeah yeah exactly but
but it's not because you think I'm Gary
Gman although I I would say maybe shoot
higher for who you're
imagining you can imagine any Napoleon
yeah there so many people to aim for yes
or or yeah and so anyhow I I was so
grateful and I wanted to tell the story
because I wanted to share that there's
hope because that that was one thing my
doctor and my wife never gave up on me
but I gave up on myself many many times
I kept going through the motions and
trying new medicine and and treatments
and ECT finally was the thing that
worked in the hospitalization and it and
it and it got me to a level that I had
never experienced in my life I had spent
my entire life sort of working at 70 75%
sometimes 80% if I could get some
momentum and then it it had kind of a
cycle where I would be productive for
nine months and then I would fall apart
and and have to start all over again so
it was very frustrating but since I have
been uh I guess I would say in
remission that was probably October of
2017 I've I've had the the the most joy
and and experienc life in a in a way
without the the heaviness and the the
fatigue that accompanied a lot of my
depressive episodes so I'm so grateful
so I was happy to share this story so
that it would give some people hope
because what I didn't realize is that
people thought I used to think when
somebody famous would would either to
commit suicide or or come out about
being depressed I would say what why
would that person be depressed and I
didn't realize that I could be that for
some people that some people would say
oh if he can get depressed and then it's
not it's not a matter of accomplishing
something it's a matter of chemistry
yeah and and and that's the thing that
that's very hard for people to
understand because the same thing you're
trying to work with is telling you this
isn't chemistry it's you you're you're
lazy you're dumb you're untalented so it
it was important that I was able to get
that story the same thing when I was a
kid or even in well into my teens and
20s when I would hear about a brilliant
author or just a a performer I loved or
anyone getting really depressed and I
would think but I don't understand yeah
yeah they they why would Elvis be
depressed uh why would anyone um who has
that be depressed and then you know as
you go through life you realize that uh
material things uh success or getting
recognized uh is um it's nice yeah but
it it is really true that it doesn't uh
have anything to do with your brain
chemistry and sometimes it can
exacerbate it and make it feel worse
like oh my God I have this and this was
supposed to be the thing that made me
feel good about myself yeah so many
people get into comedy or get into this
business because they think once I get
that yeah and everyone knows who I am
yeah and I'm driving a car that looks
like that then all my problems will be
over and when it doesn't happen yeah
rage painful rage yeah and I'm talking
about
myself but it was rage mostly that the
car isn't nicer oh well okay I come on
Tesla's nice but I want a
Bugatti and I never got one and that
sled sprawled out but it's not mine did
the to have a name yeah exactly that
when I die I'm just going to say
toog it'll be like all these reporters
will be scattered yeah to yeah whatever
Glide
right um You are uh well I'll just say
it again pleasure to know you I I really
I feel the same way you've brought me so
much joy I really admire you because uh
you're
such a highly intelligent and empathetic
comedian and you do such beautiful work
you've been through a lot which makes me
sad but also um you've come through the
other side and you're very honest about
it I think it's going to help a lot of
people but mostly if I didn't know any
of this I just I I watch these specials
I watch your comedy every time I've seen
you perform I think man that guy is so
gifted he thinks so differently than
everyone else and he's so everything is
so crafted and beautifully done the work
that goes into it so thank you what you
do is as the IR say a
Mitzvah I'm pinching myself because uh
that means so much to me but also and
this was one of the things I wanted to
mention just the the exposure you gave
me on that show all those times was I
mean it changed my life and it gave me a
touring career so I'm I'm am uh so
grateful for for what you've brought to
me even before I was on the show just
the joy and knowing that oh there are
other people who find this funny and
thought it was well we found each other
and now we're two gangly depressed guys
from
Massachusetts who know each other love
to read who love to read yay yes I love
that interview you did with uh stepen
Wright on on his book Harold which was
such a an incredible book and and he was
a guy I listened to Growing Up who made
me so happy he led the way for so many
people you made him laugh so hard that
it was just a different side of St right
my gosh you were killing him the the
universal comment I've heard uh and I'm
not patting myself on the back but just
it's funny how many people have said
this all these comedians that have never
heard him laugh and I was thinking the
same thing yes which is oh he laughs oh
my gosh CU he's so straight oh but he's
such a kind generous humble I mean
humble he's a magic he is a magical
special magical man with a hideous
Boston
accent what are you going to
do